[Aplausos]
[Música]
en los últimos meses la palabra precise
se ha convertido en un sinónimo de
apocalipsis para casi todos los medios
de comunicación al menos los de fuera
del reino unido mientras tanto en visual
político os hemos mostrado la cara más
positiva y a la vez menos conocida del
brésil ahora bien eso no significa que
todos sean ventajas
y trasladar a cientos de trabajadores
fuera de londres por culpa del break sit
y éste es sólo un ejemplo más en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo 20
bancos han anunciado ya que moverán
buena parte de sus plantillas fuera de
gran bretaña
las estimaciones más optimistas dicen
que la city de londres perderá unos
300.000 trabajadores y las más
pesimistas aseguran que esa cifra podría
llegar a los 200 mil
y si ya sé lo que estáis pensando hace
unos meses asegurábamos en este mismo
canal que la city de londres sobrevivirá
al break si significa eso que estábamos
equivocados la respuesta es no hablamos
de la capital financiera del mundo
entero no sólo de europa
londres puede mantener su influencia en
los mercados financieros de asia o
incluso eeuu
pero las finanzas europeas suponen el 35
por ciento del trabajo de la city y por
eso el hecho de no estar en la unión
europea tiene sus consecuencias y ahora
os preguntaréis a dónde van a ir todos
estos bancos cuál será la nueva capital
financiera europea tras varios meses de
competición con campañas publicitarias
incluidas parece que ya tenemos un
ganador
los bancos y las empresas planean
expandirse a frankfurt tras el break si
efectivamente todo apunta a que
frankfurt se va a convertir en el nuevo
centro financiero de europa y tal vez
uno de los más importantes del mundo
pero que tiene frankfurt que no tengan
otras ciudades como parís o madrid hoy
vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
porque los bancos dejan la city os lo
hemos contado en varias ocasiones
londres es la capital financiera del
mundo más concretamente la llamada city
de londres que es como una ciudad dentro
de una ciudad la city es un área de poco
más de un kilómetro cuadrado que tiene
sus propias leyes su propio alcalde y
hasta su propia policía
en este espacio es donde tienen sede en
los principales bancos del mundo y donde
trabajan más de trescientas mil personas
de esas 300.000 60.000 son inmigrantes
europeos que entraron en el país gracias
a estar en la unión europea y si es
cierto que reinó unido- nunca estuvo
oficialmente en el espacio de libre
circulación es decir que teóricamente el
gobierno británico podría haber cerrado
sus puertas a todos estos inmigrantes
pero en la práctica los ciudadanos
europeos podían entrar y salir en el
país como pedro por su casa
moralmente la inmigración europea a
reino unido se ha incrementado
significativamente en las últimas
décadas sin embargo parece que las cosas
van a cambiar
la primera ministra británica theresa
may está en una posición política
extremadamente débil hecha
aunque haya ganado las elecciones de
junio ha perdido buena parte de los
diputados que tenía anteriormente de
hecho ni siquiera está claro que vaya a
mantener su cargo de primera ministra
por mucho tiempo y está recibiendo
presiones tanto desde dentro de su
partido como fuera para endurecer los
controles fronterizos al que siempre he
dicho que el voto del referéndum era un
voto para que cambiáramos esa libertad
de movimiento y pusiéramos controles a
esa inmigración que viene de la unión
europea la city de londres sería una de
las zonas más afectadas de todo el país
buena parte de su éxito se debe a que
son capaces de atraer a los mejores
profesionales de todo el mundo pero si
el gobierno británico les cierra sus
puertas estos bancos que contratan
inmigrantes lo tendrán mucho más
complicado y ojo que no sólo estamos
hablando del break shit
en realidad la presión anti inmigrantes
en reino unido- va mucho más allá de las
fronteras de la unión europea
[Música]
esa me impondrá un impuesto a las
empresas de 2000 libras por cada
trabajador que contraten de fuera de la
unión europea pero esperad un momento
porque hay algo más como os decía los
conservadores de 3 am han perdido buena
parte de los escaños que tenían en la
cámara y que otro partido ha salido
beneficiado
efectivamente el partido laborista cuyo
líder jeremy corbyn es un enemigo
declarado de los bancos en su programa
ya proponía cosas como esta
los laboristas piden un impuesto a las
transacciones financieras en reino
unido- hasta ahora este impuesto era una
de las grandes bazas con las que contaba
reino unido- frente a la unión europea
como ya sabéis en bruselas llevan años
debatiendo la posibilidad de cobrar una
tasa por las transacciones
internacionales este impuesto es como el
hombre del saco en el mundo de las
finanzas ningún banco quiere verse
obligado a pagarlo y si el parlamento
británico terminará aprobando semejante
tasa muchas entidades se pensarían si
les sigue compensando seguir en londres
en otras palabras que aunque las
condiciones que se negocian en el break
sí sean maravillosas para el reino
unido- el ambiente que se respira en
este país es cada vez peor para su
sector financiero y eso explica que
tantos bancos estén empezando a abrir
sus oficinas fuera del país
pero porque elige en frankfurt ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
la capital financiera europea el mismo
día que se anunciaron los resultados del
referéndum del break city se dio el
pistoletazo de salida para competir por
el puesto de capital financiera europea
por ejemplo la comunidad de madrid' sacó
su propia campaña publicitaria para
atraer a los banqueros incluso el
ministro de economía español luis de
guindos se reunió personalmente con
directivos de bancos como jp morgan y
citi para ofrecerles impuestos bajos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en parís enmanuel macrón ha anunciado
bajadas fiscales para los bancos
londinenses sin embargo ninguna de estas
ciudades puede competir con francos
[Música]
under charter nomura holdings y daiwa
securities group han elegido la ciudad
alemana como base para mantener su
entrada en el mercado común
twitter.com food city group
goldman sachs y morgan stanley están
sopesando la misma decisión pero qué
tiene de especial esta ciudad pues bien
de entrada frankfurt es ya la sede del
banco central europeo y de muchas
grandes entidades financieras como por
ejemplo el deutsche bahn
eso significa que ya existe una red de
empresas despachos de abogados gestorías
etcétera
frankfurt además cuenta con varias
escuelas de negocios de fama
internacional una universidad y el
segundo aeropuerto más grande de europa
ahora mismo en frankfurt tenemos 400
empresas chinas 800 turcas y 1000 de
eeuu el porcentaje de empresas
británicas es muy pequeño pero bajo mi
punto de vista esto va a cambiar
automáticamente
martín por si esto fuera poco
por ciento de la población alemana habla
inglés con fluidez
[Música]
es decir que los bancos británicos
pueden enviar a sus directivos a
frankfurt tener reuniones
internacionales y contratar la población
local sin tener barreras idiomáticas
puede parecer una tontería pero en
francia sólo el 39 por ciento de la
población es capaz de entenderse en la
lengua de shakespeare y en españa el
porcentaje no llega al 25%
pero espera de un momento porque todavía
hay más como os decía en otro vídeo
alemania es un país descentralizado
donde los gobiernos regionales y los
sindicatos tienen mucha más autonomía
que en otros países gracias a esta
estructura política frankfurt puede
prometer cosas como esta las leyes
laborales alemanas hacen que sea muy
difícil despedir a gente frankfurt ha
propuesto un cambio en estas leyes que
eximiría a los banqueros o en general a
los que tienen altos sueldos de estas
regulaciones y ahora pensaba en una cosa
que es lo primero que necesita un banco
para poder establecer sus oficinas
centrales en una ciudad un edificio
verdad
lógicamente necesitarán algún lugar
donde poder construir sus oficinas pues
en ese aspecto
frankfurt es la ciudad perfecta tras la
segunda guerra mundial
frankfurt quedó reducida a cenizas y la
tuvieron que reconstruir prácticamente
desde cero en otras ciudades alemanas no
se pueden construir rascacielos para no
romper con el paisaje urbano que es más
tradicional
frankfurt puedes levantar edificios tan
altos como quieras y eso explica que
pese a que no tiene ni un millón de
habitantes su skyline parece el de una
gran metrópolis pero la cosa no se queda
aquí alemania es uno de los mercados
inmobiliarios más baratos de toda europa
tal cual como lo oís aunque los sueldos
sean altos las casas los alquileres y el
metro cuadrado os sale casi a mitad de
precio que el de parís y no hablemos ya
del de londres y espera un momento
porque creo que desde aquí puedo
escuchar a alguno de vosotros diciéndome
fonseca y qué me dices de los impuestos
para las empresas efectivamente en
alemania el impuesto de sociedades-
puede llegar hasta el 30 por ciento
mientras que en reino unido- nos supera
el 20% tenéis toda la razón pero
nuevamente el está en los
detalles
en alemania el impuesto corporativo
tiene dos segmentos distintos uno
nacional y otro regional es decir que el
gobierno federal solamente cobra un 15%
el resto depende de cada región en otras
palabras que la región de hessen que es
donde se encuentra frankfurt tiene
margen legal para reducir el impuesto y
desde luego eso serviría para atraer a
muchos más bancos londinenses que
todavía no están convencidos
en otra parte ese impuesto a las
transacciones financieras del que
hablábamos antes parece que en europa va
a tener mucha letra pequeña uno de sus
mayores defensores es precisamente el
ministro de finanzas alemán wolfgang
soul y mirad lo que dice al respecto
un queso suizo tiene algo más que
agujeros tiene que haber algo entre
ellos si no es solo un agujero no un
queso suizo
así que os dejo con esta pregunta
imaginad que sois los directivos de uno
de esos bancos londinenses y haríais os
quedaríais en londres
o tal vez empezaréis a pensar en mover
nuestras oficinas a frankfurt podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
mientras tanto si queréis saber más
sobre los planes que tiene la city para
sobrevivir al break sin hacer click en
este otro vídeo y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones
si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]